well this is a very intense moment
intense is exactly the word to describe
the conclusion to the 2018 ESPY Awards
Jennifer Garner took the stage to
present the final trophy of the night
the Arthur Ashe Courage Award which went
to hundreds of sexual abuse survivors
abused by former dr. Larry Nasser who
was sentenced to life behind bars in
February
[Music]
141 athletes survivors accepted the
award as the audience wiped away tears
Sarah Klein Tiffany Thomas Lopez and Aly
Raisman shared powerful messages on the
group's behalf we must start caring
about children's safety more than we
care about adults reputations I'm here
to tell you that you cannot silence the
strong forever don't let anyone rewrite
your story your truth does matter you
matter and you are not alone et was with
Jennifer Garner backstage what these
women went through I mean we've we all
watched it play out in front of us we
had conversations about it I know I
talked to so many people about it as a
mama though how do you talk to your
little girls about that your girls in
with my son it's so important to find a
way to talk to our kids and help them
know that they're always safe coming to
us they can tell you anything anything I
don't know I mean it bumbled my way
through it the way anyone would but it
is I think it's it's just really
important to keep the conversation going